public sénat
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce numéro d'
europe hebdo nous sommes à strasbourg au
coeur du parlement européen dans
quelques instants nous serons avec deux
invités pour commenter l'actualité et
dans cette émission focus sur les
producteurs de vins français qui sont
vent debout à l'idée de voir les
producteurs américains utiliser
l'appellation château mais d'abord
l'actualité dominée par la crise en
italie mario monti a décidé de jeter
l'épongé mais les italiens peuvent-ils
vraiment se passer de lui c'est la
question de la semaine
je ne me présente pas pour le poste de
président du conseil je brigue
simplement un siège à la chambre des
députés
où de théâtre numéro un silvio
berlusconi fait son retour sur la scène
politique italienne il estime qu'il doit
reprendre en main son pays ravagé par la
crise au parlement son parti membre de
la coalition au pouvoir a boycotté un
vote de confiance fustigeant la
politique économique menée par un
gouvernement de techniciens
coup de théâtre numéro 2 quelques heures
après les déclarations du cavalière et
mario monti annonce sa décision
irrévocable
le président du conseil italien estime
qu'il n'aura pas assez de soutien pour
faire voter sa loi budgétaire il jette
l'épongé
des élections anticipées auront lieu en
février ou mars prochain à 76 ans silvio
berlusconi se présentera pour la sixième
fois devant les italiens en appel sur à
son âge il devrait partir à la retraite
comme tout le monde les italiens n'ont
plus un sou à dépenser concrètement il
n'y a eu que des nouvelles taxes créées
et les salaires sont restées les mêmes
que ceux d'il ya dix ans retour en
arrière novembre 2011 silvio berlusconi
est président du conseil mis en cause
dans une affaire de moeurs il doit
démissionner le président georgio
napolitano appel au pouvoir l'ancien
commissaire européen mario monti érigé
en sauveur de l'italie
mais le professeur monty entouré
d'experts entame une cure d'austérité
sans précédent
le chômage augmente les impôts aussi
la consommation baisse le pays s'enfonce
dans la récession
pourtant l'italie après vingt ans de
berlusconisme retrouve son rang parmi
les nations européennes
aujourd'hui mon pti s'en est allé mais
pour combien de temps va-t-il se
représenter lui aussi car l'italie
peut-elle vraiment se passer de lui
retour à strasbourg nous sommes à deux
pas de l'hémicycle et un député italien
nous a rejoints niccolo rinaldi bonjour
je vous venez de florence vous avez été
élu sur la liste du juge di pietro et
vous siégez ici comme député européen au
sein de l'alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux pour l'europe et vous parlait
très bien français voilà comme ça on
vous a présenté alors essayons de
comprendre un peu la situation confuse
dans laquelle se trouve l'italie d'abord
pour répondre à notre question est ce
que vous pensez que l'italie peut se
passer de mario monti oui je pense que
l'italie peut se passer de m'alimenter
maillot montée a été le représentant
d'un gouvernement exceptionnelle
d'urgence
n'a jamais été élu par les citoyennes
italienne il a effectué une politique
qui en italie en jugeant peu un peu trop
sur le modèle allemande c'est à dire une
politique d'austérité très fortes donc
les pays sur certaines choses a sans
aucun doute besoin mais qui a plié les
deux piliers de notre société la famille
d'un côté et les petites moyennes
entreprises beaucoup de taxes pas des
libéralisations ce qui est par contre ce
serait nécessaire pas des bureaucrates
isation de la société italienne qui est
très importante parce que nous avons une
administration publique extrêmement
lourde de normes pour lutter contre la
corruption qui est colossale dans notre
pays qui ont été assez faibles et je
dirais une lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale ce qui est un autre anomalie de
mon pays qui n'a pas été vraiment très
efficace aujourd'hui les bilans n'est
pas vraiment positive la dette augmente
le chômage augmente et la croissance
n'est pas là
quand même fait des réformes qui étaient
nécessaires pour le pays
il a fait une réforme qui étaient très
avant celle des retraites exactement
celle celle des retraites avec quelques
problèmes là aussi et je dois dire que
c'était une réforme très important moi
je peux vous dire que je suis vie quand
même la démarche de mon parti mon parti
quand parti de centre gauche laïc qui a
au parlement européen siège dans
l'alliance des libéraux et démocratiques
avaient voté la confiance au
gouvernement montrent qu' il y a un an
avec beaucoup d'espoir beaucoup
d'attentes et ensuite de différentes
mesures que le professeur a présenté au
parlement on a constaté une déception
croissante il ya toute une série de
choses sur lesquelles on n'est pas
intervenue on continue à dépenser
énormément par exemple dans les dépenses
militaires on n'a rien fait au niveau
des grands capitaux qui sont rentrés en
italie avec une pratiquement une bonus
sans aucune pénalisation de l'étranger
de paradis paradis fiscaux on n'est pas
réussi à faire en accord bilatéral avec
la suisse et on a quand même insisté
beaucoup je répète sur la petite et
moyenne entreprise et sur la famille ça
marche pas mais aujourd'hui est ce que
mario monti et victime de la crise
économique ou des dernières phrases si
je puis dire de silvio berlusconi
il est victime d'une coalition qui l'a
soutenu jusqu'à hier qui est en
contradiction en soi même parce que
c'est un coalition avec le centre droite
et les centre gauche ensemble des
risques honni le top de la liberté a
soutenu la coalition d'ailleurs jusqu'à
hier jusqu'à hier avec ce qu'en italie
10 ans c'est un peu leur attente parti
socialiste le parti démocratique
l'équivalent du parti socialiste quelque
part français pour vous souhaitez pas
c'était une anomalie cette coalition
c'est ça aussi c'est une tout à fait
c'est une grande anomalie et ce2
regroupement vont ces contrats posées
aux prochaines élections il faut se
rappeler que l'échéance naturelle du
mandat c'était le mois d'avril donc là
on a des élections anticipées mais c'est
des élections anticipées dans moi ça ne
change pas énormément par rapport à ce
que de toute façon on arrêtait
aurait été le cas
montea a pu gouverner je dirais jusqu'à
jusqu'à aujourd'hui avec cette coalition
que je répète avait quand même tout le
temps des problèmes à son intérieur
c'est par la nature même de la coalition
et s'approchant la campagne électorale
je m'attendais je dois dire ça mais
tombe pas trop que le berlusconi a eu
envie de reprendre sa liberté de
d'action politique pour ça qu'il va
vraiment se représenter une nouvelle
fois devant les italiens moi je dirais
que cette décision de mon point de vue
c'est tout à fait ridicule parce que il
était candidat
1994 c'est la première fois alors vous
voyez combien ces vieilles la politique
italien toujours les mêmes personnes
toujours la même formule etc il est
capable comme end insisté et de se
représenter en 2000 en 2013 dans l'année
prochaine les ego sont très forts dans
les hommes politiques et mario monti on
évoque
on évoque une possibilité pour lui de se
présenter vous y croyez donc lui il peut
pas se présenter dans le point de vue
formel parce que les sénateurs avis
c'est une fonction qui nous avons dans
notre pays le président de la république
pour nommer jusqu'à cinq personnalités
une certaine stature reconnu par tout le
monde pour leur prestige sénateurs pour
toute la vie et donc c'est le cas de
monsieur montre look lui peut pas être
candidat il pourrait conduire une
coalition plus ou moins centriste mais
alors ça ça va mélanger bousculé
beaucoup la vie politique italienne
parce que il sera opposé soit par
berlusconi qui l'a soutenu jusqu'à hier
soit par les partis démocratiques qui a
son propre candidat qui a gagné les
primaires du centre gauche qui lâche
obtenu jusqu'aujourd'hui alors on suivra
ce feuilleton en tout cas l'actualité
européenne c'est aussi cette europe qui
malgré la crise a reçu le prix nobel de
la paix pour avoir su maintenir plus de
65 ans de paix sur le continent les 27
dirigeants européens le président de
l'union européenne le président de la
commission européenne et le président du
parlement européen sont tous venus à
oslo une image qui était à la une des
télévisions européennes regardez
le premier ministre irlandais et son
homologue néerlandais ont tous vers la
délégation des leaders européens aussi
sio d'oslo mais ce sont les présidents
du conseil de la commission et du
parlement qui ont reçu le prix donné à
l'union européenne pour son rôle en
faveur de la paix le comité du nobel a
expliqué que l'europe s'est construite
grâce à la réconciliation franco
allemande qui a fait que la guerre entre
les deux pays est devenu impensable
un rassemblement a été organisé samedi 8
décembre dans la capitale norvégienne
les manifestants ont critiqué les ventes
d'armes européennes dans les zones de
conflit le manque d' aide aux réfugiés
et l'absence de mesures sociales face à
la crise pour les dirigeants européens
c'est le menu est aussi l'occasion de
défendre ce que l'europe a déjà accompli
et ce qu'elle espère pour le futur
aujourd'hui il a des symboles les plus
visibles de notre unité est dans les
mains de tous je parle de l'euro la
monnaie de notre union européenne nous
la défendrons
les trois présidents européens ont fait
le déplacement à oslo leur trio
symbolise la complexité de l'union le
conseil la commission et le parlement
ces trois institutions qui ont parfois
bien du mal à donner une direction
commune aux 27 aujourd'hui les
dirigeants européens sont presque tous
là nul merkel hollande - tu iras auj
l'anc et 2 le président de la république
tchèque et le premier ministre
britannique david cameron représenté par
son numéro deux nick clegg le signe des
divisions qui traversent l'europe
alors il y avait vraiment beaucoup de
monde à oslo mais finalement à qui
s'adresse ce prix nobel vous diriez
plutôt aux dirigeants européens actuels
ou aux pères fondateurs d'hier je dirais
plutôt à la collectivité à la communauté
européenne en tant que femmes et hommes
qui la composent je pense que nous avons
un premier devoir à l'égard de l'europe
c'est de connaître notre histoire et
notre histoire ce n'est pas une histoire
entièrement positive j'ai beaucoup de
belles choses faites par l'europe et
pendant les siècles des siècles au goût
des civilisations mais on a connu je
dirais deux mille ans de guerres civiles
européennes 2000 ans interrompue soit
des violences ce soit des dominations dn
sur les autres tout ça s'est arrêté avec
les pères de l'europe il y à 50 ans plus
ou moins et les peuples européennes ont
démontré quand même la maturité la
capacité de rester en paix pendant
toutes ces décennies ce qui est tout à
fait sans précédent dans l'histoire de
l'europe il a eu un certain nombre de
polémiques sur l'assignation à l'europe
de ce prix nobel il ya certains qui
disait que l'europe mérite ne mérite pas
ça mérite à mon avis le mérite parce que
si on lit le les explications la
justification du prix nobel il s'adresse
pour ce qui a été achevé au sein de
l'europe pas pour le rôle de puissance
l'épée dans le monde sait qu'avec les
hésitations que nous avons connu dans
les balkans dans le moyen-orient
c'est quelque chose sur laquelle europe
n'a pas vraiment été un grand
protagoniste mais au sein de l'europe
franchement on a vraiment achevée
quelque chose sans précédent dans notre
histoire mais alors au delà de cet
acquis fondamental est ce que ce prix
n'est pas aussi une forme
d'avertissement ou en tout cas une
incitation à agir pour sortir de cette
crise dans le dans laquelle l'europe est
empêtrée depuis plus de deux ans et demi
maintenant moi je le prends comme un
encouragement comme une reconnaissance
quel achat que les peuples les
européennes avec le père fondateur avait
fait dans les années 50 était le choix
juste et un encouragement pour les cdd
passé
ces cortèges que nous avons vu dans
notre de votre votre service
c'est-à-dire toute cette cacophonie de
chefs d'état chefs de gouvernements
d'institutions
en parlement de la commission et tous
les états tous les états membres alors
ça franchement c'est vraiment la
complexité ça peut marcher ça peut
paraître un peu le schéma institutionnel
de l'europe a bien sûr d'ailleurs c'est
il faut pas même pas un prix nobel pour
faire ça ça suffit regardez la
croissance croyable de la chine sur la
scène internationale
d'ici 20 ans l'europe en tant que tel
soit existe unis soit ça sera une petite
provence avec un certain nombre d petit
état membre sans vraiment beaucoup de
pouvoir ni dans les commerces et ni dans
la politique étrangère un nid pour le
bien-être de leurs propres citoyens
c'est l'union total ou le chaos c'est un
peu ça je pense que c'est soit l'union
politique et union l'idée de valeur soit
c'est le
il avance c'est aussi ça le message de
ce prix nobel merci beaucoup niccolo
rinaldi d'avoir été avec nous on va
rejoindre tout de suite n'aura hamadi
qui sera avec le député eric andrieu
pour la deuxième partie de cette
émission met d'abord le reportage avec
cette question la mention château sur
les vins est elle menacée en tout cas
les états unis ont demandé à la
commission européenne l'autorisation
d'exploiter cette dénomination pour
leurs vins exportés en europe touche pas
à mon château c'est un sujet signé betty
lachguer et gwenaël durand
ou ya qu une des grandes appellations du
médoc ici plus de mille hectares de
vignes s'étendent sur la commune dont
celle de la famille cazes si le bâtiment
n'y ressemble pas c'est pourtant un
château qu'il possède dans le bordelais
c'est ainsi qu'on nomme les vins qui
proviennent à 100% de raisins récoltés
sur la propriété la définition de
château reste bien encadrés par
opposition à man négoce c'est un vin qui
est
fabriqué à partir de raisins qui vient
d'une seule et même exposé
au château lynch-bages le vin est tout
simplement un art de vivre un plaisir et
chaque visiteur vient découvrir son
vieux cuvier s'est elle étonnée qu'il
est fabriqué sur place et tout est fait
chen et surtout son grand cru
dans un premier temps de découvrir donc
ormes de pez se situe nombreux
saint-estèphe
plus loin
les dénominations château clos et
domaine remonte au 19e siècle aux yeux
du grand public c'est aujourd'hui
synonyme de qualité puisque 80 % des
vins bordelais arbore cette étiquette un
repère donc pour les consommateurs est
un gage de savoir-faire pour les
vignerons le mot est devenu une sorte de
marque je peux pas un exemple qui n'est
pas théorique mais qui est extrêmement
fréquents vous avez une même propriété
qui va appeler son vin blanc château
ceci est pour son vin rouge château ceci
donc ça correspond simplement à une
unité foncière est un type de vin qui
vient de cette unité foncière un
patrimoine qui pourrait bientôt être en
péril aide car les américains veulent
utiliser cette dénomination sur leurs
bouteilles la demande a déjà été faite à
la commission européenne
en attendant le vote les viticulteurs
bordelais s'élèvent contre cette demande
bernard farges possède lui aussi une
propriété sous le nom du domaine de
l'enclos 90 hectares de vignes dans la
petite commune de mauriac à 50 km au sud
de bordeaux et ce patrimoine il veut
tout simplement le protégé que les
américains veuillent utiliser cette
dénomination aucune françois une très
bonne nouvelle ça veut dire que les
identifie cette dénomination comme un
outil commercial qui peut être puissante
pour eux sauf que ils veulent utiliser
sa tribu et les contraintes que les
européens et les français en
l'occurrence se sont mises pour la
dénomination château s'ils ont ce début
d'hiver levin sont au repos bernard
farges s'activent car il est aussi le
président de la commission nationale des
appellations d'origine contrôlée et
organise des réunions de canton le
moment d'évoquer les sujets d'actualité
avec ses collègues viticulteurs
il ya une pression si forte que ça les
américaines vont accepter quand par
hasard à septembre que les vins dits
g20 notamment avec la masia sais pas j
millésime puis viennent puissent rentrer
sur le marché américain ce qui était
interdit par les américains alors donc
nous évidemment la ferrière
cette ouverture d'un côté c'est possible
ouverture de l'homme
mais
une demande qui serait donc le fouet de
négociations selon les viticulteurs
français côté américain difficile
d'avoir leur sentiment sur la question
seul thomas ce qu'est né a pu nous
répondre au chauffeur originaire de
boston il habite depuis deux ans et demi
avec sa compagne ils sont tous les deux
propriétaires de 65 hectares de vignes
et pour lui cette dénomination est
purement commerciale
je pense que le fait que l'industrie
viticole américaines puissent utiliser
le terme château c'est simplement du
marketing et ce serait un vol de
l'héritage français
car si vous demandez aux gens autour de
vous d'où vient à 20 dont le nom
commence par château je suis presque sûr
que 90 % d'entre eux et dire est qu'il
vient de france
reste encore d'autres interrogations
comme une utilisation du mot château en
français ils n'ont en anglais et
pourquoi les américains ne pourrait-il
pas utiliser cette mention en assumant
les mêmes règles qu'en france comme
c'est le cas au chili par exemple des
questions qui pourraient revenir sur le
devant de la scène de l'union européenne
et voici donc pour ce reportage réalisé
par betty la gare au pied des vignobles
bordelais nous sommes donc toujours au
parlement européen et entre temps eric
andrieu nous a rejoints bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes donc
députés au sein de ce parlement depuis
six mois environ vous êtes membre de la
commission agriculture et développement
rural et surtout vous êtes issu d'une
terre de vignerons si je puis dire on a
bien vu dans ce reportage que
l'appellation château pour les
américains posent problème pourtant le
chili et le canada l'utilisent d'ores et
déjà donc pourquoi cette fronde mais je
crois qu'il faut d'abord
vérifier que les que les conditions sont
requises pour l'utilisation de
l'appellation sont les mêmes pour tout
un chacun oh que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui en matière de réglementation
pour le chili en trente ans que vous
faites de référence et le canada
aujourd'hui pour ce qui est de la
demande et les américains rien n'est
rien n'est prouvé est ce que cette
raison que le comité de gestion donc de
dresser munich a été saisie pour
vérifier si réellement les conditions
requises et elle était réelle
il est bien clair que c'est une sur un
sujet grave
d'envergure pour la viticulture
française et s'est dit expressément dans
le reportage excellemment je pense qu'il
faut que nous soyons vigilants sur cet
héritage culturel donc telle sorte que
le l'avantagent produit par sept
mentions dont ne soit pas bradé un truc
à utiliser donc uniquement pour des
raisons de marketing comme il est fait
état aussi dans le reportage et pourtant
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il ya quand même
l'inde il aussi entre les états unis et
l'union européenne fin du moins la
france il ya depuis quelques années en
fait le millésime est le cépage
peuvent être indiqués sur les bouteilles
pour la production française qui a
profité aux exportations aux etats-unis
est-ce que c'est pas juste retour des
choses c'est au coeur de la discussion à
part que la question de l'utilisation de
la mention au château fait référence à
des critères bien précis c'est à dire
qu'il faut et quand on le sait dans la
profession un truqueur il faut à la fois
que le réseau soit donc sur
l'exploitation et que la transformation
du raisin en vin se fasse sur la station
elle même est là pour les stars et à ce
jour d'aucun et j'ai saisi pour cela
entre autres à travers une question
écrite la commission qui ne va pas
répondu réellement à la question afin de
savoir si éléments si ces éléments là et
est donc garantie dans la réponse qu'ils
allaient être apportées alors qui des
accords commerciaux d'autres ordres oui
mais concernant la mention château je
pense que c'est un sujet sur lequel il
faudrait que je le redis vigilant parce
qu'au delà même du produit 20 ça peut
très vite dérivé sur une un nombre de
produits protégés donc pour la france
sur lesquelles il faut pas tout
confondre salir peut y avoir des accords
commerciaux globaux à vous livre de
référence mais sur ces aspects là je
crois qu'il faut que nous soyons très
attentifs alors il ya pour l'instant la
commission européenne a reporté sa
décision la france tout cela me paraît
assez isolé sur cette position est-ce
que c'est pas juste un répit de courte
durée est ce que finalement la
commission ne va pas aller dans le sens
des états unis écoutez pour les stands
dont moi j'attends impatiemment donc je
vous dis l'avis du comité de gestion
dossier munich donka et l'avis de la
commission parce que tout ça est en
travaux alors il ya plusieurs sujets si
le fait quand même isolé mine de rien au
sein de l'union
oui mais je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
pin des landes solidaire malgré tout
derrière ce que représente de la mention
châteaudun
dans la france quoi voilà parce que si
vous voulez une question se pose plus
largement au delà de la minceur château
c'est la notion de territoire et de
marque cette question-là en
développement rural en particulier de
comment mettre en dynamique des filières
économiques que l'on parle du vin mais
ça peut toucher d'autres produits un
seul le fromage tous les produits
transformés finalement donc donc c'est
une vraie question matière de
développement rural et non pas de
protection du protectionnisme mais de
protection sans d'appropriation des
spécificités avait la volonté
d'ouverture donc sur les marchés dans
des internationaux et la question de la
mention bien au coeur du débat
aujourd'hui bon nombre d'acteurs et
réfléchissent gd marque territoriale
bien que les appels qu'on qualifie qui
viennent faire comment dire l'alchimie
entre des marques de produits dont il
approché identitaire et géographique
c'est les aop pour des produits les ige
pédant mais au delà il ya des enjeux des
rapports au patrimoine tous les
territoires sont en concurrence
aujourd'hui à grosse de même une
question d'identité pointer vers tout à
fait l'effet d'une petite au sens du
repli mais au sens donc de la
spécificité de lieux et l'ouverture aux
autres alors justement dans le cadre de
ce marché qui est quand même un marché
international nous avons rencontré
quelqu'un qui a une question à vous
poser on écoute
on va avoir des vins qui sont des vins
de qualité avec des méthodes bordelaise
voir avec des cépages bordelais qui sont
produits à des prix bien inférieurs
sur les marchés étrangers c'est pas sur
les marchés français que ça se passe et
notamment sur le marché anglais ce
marché allemand
sur le marché américain bien entendu et
ça c'est le problème des différences de
coûts de production tous les pays du
nord et pays du sud on le pressent très
général
éric andrieu est ce que la france a
perdu la bataille du vin sur le marché
international je ne le crois pas je ne
le crois pas et sur cette question là la
question du moment qui est celle liée
aux droits de plantation est au coeur
donc du sujet traité un dossier
effectivement
sur la libéralisation des droits de
plantation
évidemment je la question qui se pose
est donc de tout tout est lié finalement
sur libéralisme je pense
qu'effectivement pour la france
souhaitait donc quelque chose de
catastrophique ne sont pas au bout donc
grandir du feuilleton puisque donc le
groupe dit de haut niveau qui a été
réuni par le commissaire dacian ciolos
réuni vendredi le 14 donc décembre et
nous aurons une réponse il semblerait
que la réponse soit plutôt favorable et
même si je n'appelle pas ça des droits
de plantation ça va prendre tout ça
prendrait plutôt la dénomination
d'autorisation d'implantation mais avec
tous les éléments de critères requis
donc pour la par la profession donc ce
qu'est ce qui veut dire en fait qu'on
reviendrait en fait on sur ces droits de
plantation sur cette libéralisation
mettre en place des quotas comment ça se
passe tout à fait oui cela me rétablir
et même principe que les droits à part
qu'on appelait reppas a des droits mais
avec la volonté de régulation donc sur
le sur le marché il en aura la réponse
vendredi et est ce qu on sait combien
d'emplois sont liés à cette production
de vin en france et au plus large en
europe
alors ça c'est difficile à comptabiliser
pascal abrial emplois directs dont liés
à la filière dont il ya tout ce qui
tourne autour des emplois induits quoi
pour moi l'état dont par exemple on met
dans le bordelais s'est déjà 56 à
60 mille emplois donc ça veut dire sur 2
voilà mesure ce que ça représente quand
je cours je comment dire je
je mets boutabout bordelais la nodo
crucial de grandes sud le sud-ouest
circonscription serveurs sénat mille
emplois directs et donc les droits de
plantation et cette appellation château
risquerait de mettre à mal en fait
acceptation aujourd'hui nous perdions
sur les deux tableaux à la fois celui de
la mention est celui des droits
effectivement je pense que la filière
viticole eux seraient mises à mal pour
la france alors rapidement dernière
question je reviens sur la question je
vous posais tout à l'heure est ce que la
france face aux vins australiens sud
américains nord américain n'a pas un
petit peu perdu la bataille non
sincèrement je ne crois pas à la france
est riche de la qualité de ses terroirs
c'est pour cette raison que la question
de la mention il est aussi importante
serait qu on a une place à
l'international lié à nos spécificités
territoriales les sessions de dimensions
je pense c'est pas que c'est pas qu'une
vue de l'esprit quoi je pense qu'il faut
vraiment mener la bataille avec force et
véhémence telle que nous le faisons les
uns et les autres parce que il en va de
l'avenir la spécificité de l'agriculture
française et de la viticulture française
merci beaucoup eric andrieu d'avoir été
notre invité est on suivra de toute
façon cette problématique pour nous
c'est la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve très bientôt en janvier sur les
chaînes parlementaires pour un nouvel
épisode d' europe hebdo et d'ici là
bonne suite de programmes et surtout
bonne fête